Senator Marco Rubio thank you for the
interview and welcome to the program
thank you
US Secretary of State Rex Tillerson says
that there won't be any normal relations
with Russia because of the situation in
Ukraine the one Ukraine does it mean
that the US government regards Russia as
an enemy
I wouldn't the Russian people are not
our enemy and certainly Vladimir Putin's
government behaves like an adversary in
many theaters and in many places it's
regrettable I think that a partnership
between the United States the American
people and the Russian people would
benefit both peoples and would be great
for the world but the direction the
Vladimir Putin has chosen to take Russia
has has made that very difficult to
achieve in Ukraine and Crimea and before
that Georgia are examples of things that
he does that put him at odds with what
the world thinks is the right thing to
do and certainly what the United States
thinks is the right thing to do and so
we well we must always deal with the
Russian government because of the
realities of geopolitics we don't need
to do so with at the expense of the
rights of our fellow man and the Russian
people's desire to live in a free
pluralistic democratic society where the
rights are respected and we also don't
have to do that and and and by
abandoning the rights of the people in
Ukraine and another Georgia and other
places from having their territorial
integrity respected there gonna be a
detailed report on Russian oligarchs and
senior Russian officials who are
involved in foreign policy and this
report will be presented before they
begin a February next year what are your
expectations my expectations that
they'll confirm if the report is done
appropriately and accurately what we've
long known and that is that Vladimir
Putin long ago made the decision that
his role was to place Russia once again
in the world is a great power and
alternative to the United States and to
the international order which in and of
itself is not a terrible
admission but the way he's chosen to do
it internally is by controlling media
and controlling industry and so you see
how he has placed loyalists and people
who's standing there income and standard
of living is dependent upon his
willingness to allow them to benefit
from his power so I think the reports
will show that there is a group of elite
oligarchs in Russia that control the
nation's wealth because of their
relationship with Vladimir Putin and in
exchange they're his agents around the
world that he uses for his own purposes
both financial and political and who is
at risk because in Russia everybody I
mean all these wealthy people are
oligarchs that they're really nervous
who's at risk well I would say the the
report will speak for itself so this is
not an appropriate thing to stand out
beforehand and name names let the
reports stand there suffice it to say
that I imagine people are nervous it
should be nervous because while I'm not
saying it's impossible and that there
aren't people that have not done
anything wrong and have been financially
successful it is very difficult if not
near impossible to be a billionaire or a
multi-millionaire in today's Russia
without the blessing and the
acquiescence and the support of Vladimir
Putin he decides who gets to make the
money and that's directly proportional
to his ability to control you and your
willingness to work and on his behalf
and be his agent and not disrupt but
what he has set up for himself which is
his vision of a sort of a new czar but
what will be the consequences for those
people who will appear on this list well
I think their consequences with regards
to the United States policy is that
their access to both their finances and
their visits to the United States could
be curtailed or eliminated they could
lose visas they could lose the ability
to access resources here in the United
States I think that would be one of the
consequences that you could see on
behalf of the US government we'll see
how the rest of the world reacts yes
president
Donald Trump makes headlines here in the
United States and in the world because
of his Russia connections what might be
their final political consequences for
president of the
United States in the aftermath of all
these investigations well the one thing
about here and compared the Vladimir
Putin's government is that we have a
system of checks and balances and we
have a system of rule of law and so
right now there's suspicions and
allegations that have been made and
they're being investigated by
professional investigators who will make
decisions based on the facts if there's
nothing there there's nothing there and
if there is well then we'll see where
that leads us
and that's ongoing so I you know I think
ultimately we'll let that play itself
out and we'll go wherever the truth
takes us because that's the way our
system works and people that are accused
of a right to defend themselves and/or
prove their innocence and the government
has a burden to prove that and we're not
at that stage here but what I think is
abundantly clear is that bloddy more
potent chose to interfere in the US
elections not so much to favor one
candidate over another in my opinion but
to sow instability too so I think in
many ways he blames the United States
for the protests against corruption and
against him that took place in 2010 in
2011 in 2009 and in later part of the
last decade early part of this decade he
thinks somehow the United States was
behind it and in many ways this was a
part of getting revenge for that and I
think the other part of it is quite
frankly he wanted to destabilize the US
Republican and be able to go back and
say to his own people into the world
that America is in no position to
lecture anyone about democracy their own
democracy is flawed which I don't
necessarily disagree that we're not
perfect there's no doubt that we're not
perfect the difference is that our
imperfections are debated openly in a
free society and not presented through a
state controlled media loyal to one
person and one regime but I'm talking
about these exactly investigations if
they prove that from had connections
with Russia Ward would be the
consequences for him for his political
career what the risk of impeachment for
example well that's going we're way
ahead of ourselves when talking about
words like impeachment and things that
we're not at that stage or anywhere
close to it right now we have an
investigation ongoing and it may lead
nothing it may lead to certain
individuals we've already seen a couple
of indictments but it may not ultimate
we prove anything that the president did
anything wrong and so we need to wait
for that I want to prejudge that and it
would be unfair and prejudicial to do it
but ultimately this I have confidence in
the people that are doing this
investigation are serious and
professional people the truth is going
to be out there for our courts to look
at in the case of the individuals that
have been indicted or maybe indicted and
for the voters to look at in the case of
in case of anybody else is in an elected
office so we need to wait for all of
that anything that gets ahead of it
wouldn't be fair to the accused and
wouldn't be fair to the truth so we've
got away for that process to work itself
out the important thing is we have a
process and that process will lead us to
facts and will lead us to truth and then
both voters and our court system can
make decisions based on that and what in
your estimation what is the real impact
of Russia on the presidential election
here I don't think it impacted the
outcome but we most certainly need to be
aware that foreign governments tried to
exploit legitimate divisions in American
society for purposes of creating chaos I
think Vlad and Rutan's ultimate goal was
not the election of one candidate versus
another although he may have personally
preferred one candidate but I think his
ultimate goal was to ensure that whoever
was elected the next united state
president did so with her credibility
damaged and and I also think he wanted
to exploit what would already existing
divisions in American society for
purposes of forcing us to go through
what we're going through right now which
is investigations divisive debates talk
about impeachment and the like it's
destabilizing and this is a pattern that
has repeated itself not simply in the US
elections we saw an attempt to do it in
France and in Germany and Montenegro and
Bulgaria most recently and potentially
even now in Mexico this year this is a
sort of sort of hybrid warfare type
concept that he has adopted and it's in
line with his training as a
a KGB officer and and the sort of
propaganda efforts that existed during
the Cold War without the internet and
without without Twitter and Facebook
you're talking about propaganda and I
have a question that about propaganda
Russia today played a role in the
presidential election I couldn't to the
reports that were published Russia today
has been recently recognized or labeled
as one agent and it lost its
accreditation and the Congress do you
support because they're not a legitimate
news agency they are controlled by a
government agency of another country but
but I would go further and say that
almost all press in Russia is one of the
things Lattimer Putin learned in late
1999 2000 2001 period was he needed to
control the media he could no longer
allow there to be media voices that were
dissenting from and him and that's what
he's done he knows that the access to
information gives them power and so
today you see the in Russia the Russian
people and you see these public opinion
polls and you're not surprised by it
because the information they're being
fed is wrong anybody who opposes the
Putin regime is characterized as an
outsider an alien somebody who isn't you
know whose values are different from the
rest of the country so there's no space
for legitimate dissent they lie about
the presence of Russian troops in
Ukraine when there was clear reality
that they were there they lie about
what's happening in in Syria and the
role the United States has played and so
when a country and a people only have
access to sources of information
controlled by those in power the
information they're going to get isn't
necessarily based on truth and there was
no access to alternative and and I by
the way I don't think it's a coincidence
that the recent few months ago the
protests in Russia against corruption
were largely led historically and Russia
protests have been led by older
working-class folks in this case the
protests were of are younger people who
consume information on the Internet
not through the state-controlled
propaganda in Russia so there's no doubt
that RT is a is an agent of influence
the US has television and radio stations
abroad but we don't deny that that's
what they are voice of
America you know a free Europe officer
Cuba broadcasting we admit that those
are media entities that the US
government doesn't for purposes of
disseminating information that we
believe is truthful in the case of
Russia they pretend that in the case of
Putin he pretends that RT is a
legitimate news agency it is not it is a
propaganda arm of Russian intelligence
in the Ryan the Putin government even
gone will receive an unprecedented
budget for resister Russian aggression
it's 4.6 billion dollars and also is
implied by this budget that Ukraine will
get level defensive weapons do you
support I do and I and I know and I know
that yeah I do support it and someone
who I think would understand this
concept very well is Vladimir Putin who
has often spoken publicly about the need
for balance and so what happens if
there's an imbalance what happens if two
neighboring nations there's a there's a
defense and balance and one nation
believes that it could win an armed
conflict against another that's an
invitation for aggression and so from
our point of view it is important that
our allies in your crane and in Europe
and around the world have the ability to
have some level of balance because
weakness invites aggression and it
invites miscalculation so that's what we
seek is simply to support our allies so
there can be a strategic balance that
prevents war not instigates it I know
that you're closely follow Latin America
and in Israel Russia restructured
Venezuela's debt and recent months why
do you think what is the assessment of
Russia's role in Latin America and in
particular in Venezuela I I think it's
ultimately I mean Putin's ability to
project power globally is quite limited
at the end of the day it's more flashed
and an impact in the case of Venezuela
in particular they do oh and Russia
money or Russian owned entities money
they don't have the cash to repay it so
he's been they've been willing to
restructure the payment on the debt and
they've taken as collateral the
resources that belong to the Venezuelan
people and they've moved away for
example for
control over Citgo and towards control
of gas and oil fields instead real
property outside the jurisdiction of the
United States so I think that ultimately
he wants to get paid they want to get
paid the the Russian entities do and
they're hopeful that there'll be a
future government in Venezuela that
could do so but the other my view is
they probably feel SIA that they've
already invested so much in that
relationship that to walk away from it
not knowing what's going to replace it
it doesn't make a lot of sense so you
know do I think that they help the
Maduro regime and they do but not nearly
enough to save it beyond that in a
places like Cuba and Nicaragua and and
those are the two other places where you
see the the Putin government try to play
a little bit of a role in basing
agreements and the like so we're aware
of the presence we certainly think that
they try to use that to leverage against
us a little bit but I'm not we're
concerned but not deeply concerned about
it president Trump introduced two major
initiatives this major tax reform that
the United States I haven't seen since
the eighties and his recent initiative
to recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel
do you support both I do on tax reform
again because of our democratic nature
here in this country we have differences
of opinion on out what it should look
like and we're gonna have a very vibrant
and open debate in a dictatorship and a
tyranny in an oligarchy and an autocracy
those decisions are made in a closed
room and they tell you what it's going
to be they don't ask you your opinion
here we're going to have a chance to
mold it and it won't be something I'm
agree with 100% but if it makes things
better it's the kind of thing I'll
support with regards to Jerusalem I
think it's offensive that Israel's the
only country in the world that doesn't
get to decide what its own capital is it
is most certainly its seat of government
it has been for a very long period of
time
the Jewish people have a long and
well-documented link to the to the holy
city there and I think they've been very
respectful of the role that other faiths
play Christianity and Islam as well and
and will and have continued to be
committed to doing so so I've called for
that for many years and I'm supportive
of the fact that that decision was
finally made you work with Ivanka Trump
on tax relief before
people with kids what is the real
influence on of Ivanka Trump on her
father's decisions well I think that
she's a very important advocate for the
concept that working families raising
children face rising cost in the 21st
century and they need assistance and
they need our tax code to recognize it
and so of a company invest money in a
machine the tax code lets them keep that
money but if families are raising
children the tax code doesn't take that
into account so I'm just trying to
create equality between companies and
people and she's been very supportive of
that concept so I do think that she is
someone who has gotten the president in
the White House to care about that issue
because it's not something he campaigned
on and so she's been an important ally
in that fight and what's the view of the
American Society of the fact that
President Trump brought some members of
his family into the White House well
it's something we haven't seen since the
Kennedy administration but by and large
I don't think that there were a country
with some diverse opinions I think the
public opinion polls in the last
election reflected that were pretty
evenly divided between those that have
supported the president and those that
did not it was a very close election and
he ultimately won and I would say that
of the people that have problems
President Trump that's probably the
lowest item on their list there are a
lot of other things that they opposed
and as far as the role that they've
played his family members being his
son-in-law and his daughter as I said
his daughters had a very productive role
and his son-in-law seems to have
generally as well so I would say that
even for opponents of President Trump
the presence of Jared and Ivanka in the
administration is probably the least of
their complaints given some of the other
things that they have problems with my
last question it's a personal question
because you introduced a legislation to
designate the block in front of the
Russian embassy as Boris Nemtsov Plaza
in honor of my father why do you think
it is important yes two things one I
hope that soon
you've sooner rather than later there
will be a new Russian government that
will be proud that that name is on the
street not offended by it and the second
is that this is an issue that an
investigation that deserves an answer
we've seen individuals that were
convicted
whether it was them or not what about
why it happened who did it is one thing
why they did it is another this is a
political assassination this was a
prominent person in government that for
many years have been a part of
government who had a difference of
opinion with the direction that the
country was headed under Vladimir Putin
and it cost him his life and not only do
what we never know as long as Putin is
in power but they almost looked like it
doesn't matter and I think that that
that speaks not simply to the gloss of
the nation but to its soul and to what
does it mean to a society when you're
telling them that political opponents
it's okay to kill them because it what
does that do to a country into its
future into its collective soul as a
nation into its identity so this goes
well beyond simply one murder it goes to
be it speaks volumes to the future of a
society that that has some important
decisions to make here over the next
decade so thank you very much thank you